can you speak a little bit
more to the connection between aliens
and technology that
jacques valet had in his own one
individual mind
that's very tempting to kind of separate
as two
separate endeavors
why did you come to believe that they
are
one and the same or at least part of the
same
uh intellectual journey thanks for
asking that again
because nobody asks me that question and
it's central to my project so
jacques was a huge influence is a huge
influence on me
um he taught me a lot um
i had he gave me access to some of his
information that's that he keeps
but a lot of his information is actually
there out there for everyone to read
um he has an academia.edu page and he
just
so he didn't have this unfortunately
when i was
doing my research in 2012 and 2013 so i
had to go back and do micro fish
type stuff you know what i did was i
began to read everything that he wrote
and he actually gave me a lot of his
books too
and he told me i remember um he dropped
me off from
this is actually quite interesting if
you allow me to tell you a little story
please
okay and it also includes ayahuasca so
great every star includes ayahuasca has
a great story
okay so i was at a conference and it was
a small conference
of very interesting people in california
on the pacific ocean
and jacques was there and um this is
actually
opens my book this is the book this is
the i
uh go ice the preface to my book i go on
this ride he takes me through silicon
valley
i've lived there right my grandparents
grew up in the same place that he
raised his children in belmont and so um
but we're there with
robbie graham who's a great ufologist in
his own right
and um and film theorist
i highly recommend his work um so we
were together and he was taking us to
san francisco where i was gonna meet my
brother
who's going to take me home and so he
took us on this long journey
and he talked to us and as we got out of
the car um
he gave me several of his books and one
in particular he gave me he said
read this first i was like okay i
definitely will read that first
okay so this is how the ayahuasca
figures in so
um we were i didn't take it nor have i
taken it okay so we're
at this place and um in california
and alex gray and his wife were there
and they were talking about
their experiences with psychedelics you
know he's an amazing
visionary artist okay so he he believes
that there's this
place that you can enter and he and his
wife would enter this
space with either you know ayahuasca
or lsd or something like that and they
would not talk to each other but they
would be having the same exact
experience so they would it was almost
like having the same dream
right okay so so somehow that whole
event with jacques there and them
talking about their
experiences in these realms of which
religious studies people are quite
familiar by the way because visionary
experiences are what we study
so all of this seems super familiar to
me and i recognize
that immediately that jacques
that it hit me like you know very
obvious
that ufos and these experiences
and technology all seemed
they were all meshed together and i knew
that i had to take them
i knew i had to read everything jacques
ever wrote and the best stuff he's
written by the way
is the stu his little essays that he
wrote in the 1970s and there were
peer-reviewed essays
about the beginning of the internet and
how a lot of it was based on
um basically like
um neural connection with the internet
like somehow
psychic connection through the internet
with others and things like that so the
mind the brain is a biological neural
network there's a
uh this connection between visual
neurons and so on and that's what
ultimately is able to have uh memories
and has
cognitive ability and is able to uh
perceive the world
and generate ideas and those ideas are
then
spread on the internet even from the
very early days to other humans so it
gets
injected or travels into the brains of
other humans and that goes around in
there and then
spits out other stuff and it goes back
and forth so it's
it's nice to think of the network that's
in our mind individual mind
as i mean um very much
even deeply connected to the network
that is the connection between
humans through the internet and so in
that sense
jacques saw the internet as this as this
powerful
um as a source of power and wisdom that
is beyond our own
exactly that's external to us like a non
like you know if you could call it
autonomous ai right right it's non-human
intelligence in a sense even though
humans are a part of it
yes or we're invaded by it or you know
whatever you want to call it
yeah whoever right it's the chicken and
the egg right
so if i can go on the i want to
experience this oh yes
i'm not done with that yeah so and this
is so this is where
i come to this idea that um
we're in this space we're in now a new
space of religion of religiosity
so what happens is then i and it's like
a biosphere
and i'll talk about that in a minute so
we so so jacques takes us back
we get to san francisco and my brother
who is your straight lace person you
know army guy
and everything like that um i get into
his car and the first thing he tells me
is
i took ayahuasca and i was like what
he goes it's gonna save humanity
great yeah as i mentioned to you offline
i talked to matthew johnson he's a
hopkins professor on uh
he's a really a scholar of most
he's he's studying most drugs he's also
really deeply studied cocaine all those
stuff and
negative effects and he's focused on a
lot of positive effects of the different
psychedelics
it's kind of fascinating so i'm very
much
interested in exploring
the science of what these things do to
the
to the human mind and also personally
exploring it
although it's like this weird gray area
which he he's he's
masterful at which is he's a professor
at john hopkins one of the most
prestigious universities in the world
and
and doing large-scale studies of this
stuff
and until until he got a lot of money
for these studies
even in uh hopkins itself there's not
much risk
it's not even respect it was like people
just didn't want to talk about it
as a legitimate field of inquiry it's
kind of fascinating
how hesitant we are as a little
human civilization to uh legitimize
the exploration of the mysterious of
whatever the definition of the
mysterious is for that particular period
of time
so for us now there's like little groups
of things like i would say consciousness
in the space of like computer science
research is something that's still like
i don't know maybe let philosophers kick
it around for a little longer
and then certainly extraterrestrial life
forms
from um in most
formulations of that problem space
is still the other it's still the source
of the mysterious
except maybe like seti which is like
how can we detect signals from far away
alien intelligences that would be able
to
uh perceive yeah it's uh
and psychedelics is another one of those
that's like we're starting to see
okay well can we um try to see if
there's some
medical applications of like helping you
get
like he does studies of help you quit
smoking or help you in some kind of
treatment of some disease
and he's sneaking into that i mean it's
like openly sneaking into it he's doing
studies on it of like how can you expand
the mind with these tools and what can
the mind discover
through psychedelics and so on and we're
like slowly creeping into the space
of being able to explore these
mysterious questions but it's like
it sucks that sometimes a lot of people
have to die
meaning sorry uh they have to age out
like it's like faculty have a
and people have a fixed set of ideas and
they stick by them
and in order for new ideas to come in
then the
young folks have to be born with the pot
with an open mind the possibility of
those ideas and then they have to become
old enough
and get a's in school and whatever to to
uh
to then carry those ideas forward so you
know the acceptance of the
exploration of the mysterious takes time
it's kind of sad
it is sad i agree
you